votre nombre démontrent que ces états
généraux de la fédération de paris
rencontre un très grand succès nous
sommes obligés d'ailleurs d'ouvrir une
salle également en bas et je salue nos
amis qui sont dans cette salle où ils
n'ont pas le contact physique avec nous
mais en tout cas en tout cas et recevoir
les les images donc nous allons tout au
long de cette matinée
essayez de réfléchir sur un certain
nombre de sujets de préoccupation des
parisiens quelques mots simplement
d'ouverture de sept de ces états
généraux
après quoi c'est très tard
départementale frédéric péchenard
s'exprimera une condition nécessaire
mais non suffisante pour gagner les
élections à venir ce qui est notre
ambition évidemment à tous
comme ce fut le cas au départemental
c'est la reconstruction
la reconstruction de notre parti après
les épreuves que nous sommes parvenus à
surmonter qui aurait pu souvenez-vous
provoqué notre disparition sans y
revenir je voudrais simplement dire
combien j'ai été impressionné en tant
que président de cette fédération par
l'attitude exemplaire des militants de
l'ump qui ont su lui garder finalement
leur confiance et lorsque en tant que
président je vous écris pour vous
exhorter à maintenir votre adhésion
parce qu'en tant que seul parti
d'alternance crédible notre
responsabilité face aux français était
immense pas un pas un d'entre vous n'a
renvoyé sa carte dans la tente sans
doute de jours meilleurs
eh bien ceux ci ont fini par arriver
mais chers amis d'abord grâce au
triumvirat formé par nos trois anciens
premiers ministres qui ont redonné
confiance à un mouvement qu'il avait
perdue et depuis l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy le travail s'est amplifiée à tel
point que notre parti refonder
fonctionne désormais normalement
correspondant mieux ainsi aux
aspirations des français d'aujourd'hui
permettant de tourner une page que tous
voulaient oublier et rendre à notre
formation
tellement abîmé une crédibilité
qui avait disparu et conformément aux
engagements pris et après un intense
travail préparatoire sur les nouveaux
statuts
réalisé sous l'autorité de nathalie
kosciusko morizet au sein de groupes de
travail qui se sont réunis pendant
plusieurs mois
trois axes ont été poursuivis
démocratisation décentralisation
transparence et vous avez vous même
souvenez vous en été consulté par le
biais d'un questionnaire en ligne de 55
questions et par une réunion de tous les
adhérents de la fédération que j'ai
convié ici même en présence de nathalie
des élus parisiens
et puis vous avez adopté ses nouveaux
statuts massivement d'ailleurs en mai
dernier
alors cette réforme repose sur un
principe fondamental celui de la
démocratie interne en vous rendant la
parole et moi comprise ente faut des
deux fédérations
je peux vous assurer que je m'assigne
l'objectif avec nos secrétaires
départementale d'eure c'est de faire
vivre très intensément ces nouveaux
statuts vous élirez ainsi par exemple
directement le président de votre
fédération le 30 janvier prochain vous
serez consulter régulièrement par
internet et vous l'êtes déjà sur toutes
les questions politiques majeures il ya
des jeux de consultations qui ont eu un
grand succès également sur l'immigration
le code du travail
et quand cela s'avèrera nécessaire sur
les investitures local l'élection comme
la parité sont désormais la règle pour
la composition de toutes les instances
de direction tels le bureau politique
qui a fait place aux élus non
parlementaire et cerise sur le gâteau
quand même il faut le préciser
les élus doivent désormais être ce qui
me paraît tout à fait normal entre nous
à jour de leur cotisation pour être élu
peut être investi d'abord aient dû
ensuite davantage de moyens sont donnés
aux fédérations sur le plan
organisationnel administratif et
financier comme aux circonscriptions
qu'ils peuvent s'organiser notamment à
paris et c'est assez nouveau sur la base
des arrondissements qui correspond mieux
finalement la géographie parisienne une
charte négociée qui fixe les objectifs à
atteindre en terme de nombre d'adhérents
et d'activités est également prévu et la
base militante a été élargi par la
possibilité d'être associés aux parties
afin de pouvoir participer à certaines
actions sans pour autant être
adhérent au sens habituel traditionnel
du terme enfin des primaires ouvertes
vous le savez vous permettront les 20 et
27 novembre 2016 de choisir celui des
nôtres que vous souhaitez porter à
l'elysée bref un parti moderne où le
débat est assumée ou vous votez sur le
choix des candidats et des projets où la
transparence est de mise
à tous les niveaux pour redonner
confiance aux français qui ne croient
plus en la politique
les républicains définissent ainsi en
quelque sorte pardonner les modestie du
propos mais je crois profondément la
citoyenneté du 21e siècle où les
citoyens ont toujours le dernier mot nos
victoires électorales futurs dépendront
de la réussite de ce pari qui est assez
bien entamé d'ailleurs et aussi du
projet bien sûr que nous soumettrons aux
français et qui doit profondément est
structurellement réformer tout le champ
de l'action publique
alors avant que frédéric nous présente
la nouvelle équipe départementale qui
siège à ses côtés en nombre je veux
d'abord évidemment et vous le
comprendrez vandromme l'hommage qu'elle
mérite à l'équipe sortante est d'abord à
jean jacques giannesini devenir le
meilleur des militants
excuse moi tu vas rougir mais je disais
le meilleur des militants qui m'a
apporté une aide si précieuse et qui
continue être le vice-président notre
fédération
le trio de choc des délégués fédéraux
catherine dumas jean pierre lecoq
vincent roger exemple je salue les sept
secrétaires départementaux adjoints tous
doivent être saluées comme notre
déléguée à la jeunesse françois merlet à
dire le plus ancien des jeunes le plus
jeune des anciens je sais pas trop
comment il faut focaliser
un mot encore sur notre trésorier bien
sûr après benessiano qui siège également
à la tribune et qui sera reconduit qui
occupent certainement le rôle le plus
ingrat et son accueil son actif avec
beaucoup de rigueur
d'ailleurs les finances de la fédération
sont remises à flot
ce qui n'a pas été une mince affaire ce
qui nous permettra de proposer
prochainement j'espère l'ouverture de
permanence nouvelle dans l'est parisien
comme je l'avais promis emportant
l'effort dans les arrondissements de
reconquête bien sûr enfin nos deux
permanents permettez-moi des sites et
lila joao mérite une
son spécial aussi pour leur dénuement
ils viennent de le démontrer en
organisant de main de maître le
déménagement de la fédération désormais
de retour au siège national sachez que
votre fédération
et bien désormais ici dans ses locaux au
quatrième étage
nous les y inaugure ont d'ailleurs
officiellement lors du buffet de la fin
de matinée auxquels bien sûr vous êtes
tous cordialement conviés voilà la kia
police mme buffet ils ont raison la con
déjà fin alors 7 baptisé va nous
permettre d'évoquer deux sujets
essentiels pour les parisiens il fallait
sélectionner à nous font d'autres états
généraux avec d'autres questions qui
sont analysés étudier la sécurité et le
logement qui nous ont paru être des
questions tout à fait prioritaire
évidemment mais aussi pendant un petit
moment jusqu'à 10 heures ou presque la
sécu la vie la vie de notre fédération
l'animation de notre fédération et pour
ce faire je passe aussitôt la parole à
notre secrétaire départemental afin
qu'en premier lieu il présente sa
nouvelle équipe et je vous à dire tout
le plaisir que j'ai à travailler avec
lui nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps nous nous apprécions je crois
dans d'autres fonctions dans lesquelles
nous nous sommes beaucoup fréquenté une
certaine époque je suis heureux de le
retrouver ici parce que je connais sa
rigueur son sens de l'éthique son
efficacité sa compétence et je sais que
nous formons un tandem particulièrement
unis et c'est très important pour notre
fédération et que le travail que nous
allons réaliser nous permettra
d'emporter très aisément toutes les
prochaines élections qui concerneront
pas relié également la france merci à
toutes et à tous